several thousand light years away from
the sun
there is a fiery inferno the surface of
a small star is so
scorching hot that its heat reduces any
celestial bodies in the neighboring
parts of space
to ashes it is burning so furiously that
it barely remains in its shape
this object is about to explode and the
blast is going to produce an incredibly
powerful flare
to date we know just a few such-like
objects
unique and dangerous wr 102
is the hottest star in the universe
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
temperatures of any star's interiors are
incredibly high
it is hardly surprising as thermonuclear
synthesis
that is the main energy source of all
stars can take place
only in these extreme conditions when
two atoms of hydrogen merge
they produce an atom of helium and
release an electron and several
neutrinos
in addition a great amount of energy is
released during the process
still the hydrogen helium synthesis
isn't the only process that heats up
stars
at higher temperatures other elements
may take part in chemical reactions as
well
for example lithium carbon or oxygen
in this case cores of heavier elements
are produced
such as sulfur magnesium or phosphorus
their charge is higher and they repel
each other more robustly much more
energy is needed to overcome this
resistance
when a main sequence star depletes most
of its hydrogen supply
it starts to expand and cool off
with time it ends up as a red giant
it will continue to burn due to
thermonuclear reactions of helium
transforming into carbon and oxygen
the lighter the star however the less
time it will continue to burn
eventually becoming unstable it sheds
its outer layers and goes supernova
this leaves it a white dwarf with no
resources to fuel
any thermonuclear reactions anymore
with all its energy sources depleted it
is forced to gradually cool off
interestingly when the mass of a star is
higher than a certain value
heavy thermonuclear synthesis may become
the star's main energy source even after
all hydrogen has been used up
such celestial objects are referred to
as wolfray at stars
this class of space objects was
discovered back in 1867 by the french
astronomers
charles wolf and george reyette the
scientists attention was scored by
anomalously bright emission lines of
heavy elements in these stars spectra
as for the inner makeup of these unusual
celestial objects
it was accounted for much later
stars of this class are generally heavy
they have quite a meager supply of
hydrogen
and are in the final stages of their
revolution
wolfrey had stars are extremely rare to
date
just a few hundred of them have been
discovered in our galaxy
as for their overall count in the milky
way it is estimated that there can't be
over 2 000
celestial objects of this class
read stars are subdivided into three
main sequences
depending on the prevalent element in
the spectrum
nitrogen carbon and oxygen sequences
each of them in its turn is subdivided
into several types
as for the hottest star in the studied
universe
it falls into the category of the oxygen
spectral sequence ones
the celestial body which is now known as
wr102
was discovered back in 1971
at first it was mistaken for the optical
counterpart of the x-ray source
gx-3 plus one however
further observations revealed that there
were two completely different
objects according to data
acquired thanks to spectral analysis the
discovered star had unusually bright
oxygen lines in its radiation spectrum
thus in 1982 wr
102 and four more bright stars became
the first to form a new class
spectral analysis showed that the star's
surface temperature reaches
over 210 000 kelvin
this makes wr 102 approximately
36 times as hot as our sun
the luminosity of the scorching hot
object is unbelievable
it is estimated at over three hundred
and eighty thousand
times that of the sun
wr102 lies about ten thousand light
years away
the star is located in the part of the
sky with the constellation sagittarius
incidentally in spite of its
exceptionally high luminosity
it can't be seen with the naked eye as
it is too far away from us
[Music]
wr-102 belongs to the extremely rare
star class
wo2 containing great amounts of oxygen
and almost no hydrogen
it mainly relies on the merging of heavy
cores of such elements as neon
carbon and oxygen as its sources of
energy
to date only nine objects of this class
have been discovered
with four of them located in the milky
way and the other five in other galaxies
there are two factors that make oxygen
spectral sequence stars rare
firstly there are very few of wolfrey
had stars around because only stars were
the mass not less than 40 solar masses
are potential candidates to become ones
secondly this class represents the final
stage of evolution of stars of this type
the stage may last anything from a
thousand to ten thousand years
which is mere seconds in astronomical
terms
being of comparatively modest dimensions
wr102
is notably quite a dense star with its
radius measuring just 58 percent that of
the sun
its mass on the other hand is estimated
at 15 to 18
solar masses on its birth it is thought
to have been as heavy as 40 to 60 solar
masses
still the high temperature and robust
chemical reactions in the star's
interior
cause an exceptionally powerful stellar
wind whose particle's velocity is over
5000 kilometers per second
it takes wr 102 just a few months to
lose one
earth mass worth of material on account
of its stellar wind
at this rate of particle emission the
star is going to lose one sun mass worth
of material
in the course of 10 000 years
[Music]
there are no planets orbiting wr 102
but it is shrouded in a gas envelope not
dense
and exposed to powerful ultraviolet
radiation and strong stellar wind
the envelope gets contracted and ionized
which sustains its elaborate structure
of protuberances and arches
all around the star according to a
proposed theory
the gas cloud around wr102 may probably
be remnants of the former hydrogen
outer layer of the star another theory
maintains that the cloud came to be as a
result of the particle flow
emitted by the star wr102 is not the
only outstandingly blistering place in
the universe
for example wr 142
wr30a and wr93b
as well as the central stein the bug
nebula ngc
6302 are as hot as around
200 000 kelvin some white dwarfs may
have almost the same surface temperature
however all these are no match to
neutron stars
when neutron stars are born their
temperatures may reach a staggering
hundred billion
kelvin active neutrino emissions cool
them off comparatively rapidly
but either way the surface temperature
of any neutron star is never less than a
few hundred thousand kelvin
as for their cause they must admittedly
be hotter still having said that
it is highly improbable that the
ultimate temperature record is ever
going to be beaten
according to today's cosmological
concepts the temperature of the universe
at the moment of the hypothetical big
bang was approximately 1.4 times
10 to the power of 32 kelvin a
fundamental physical constant
this value is referred to as the planck
temperature
contemporary physics is not capable of
defining a substance of a higher
temperature
as physical laws are distorted beyond
any recognition in such incredibly harsh
conditions
quite beyond our imagination
getting back to wr 102 judging by the
data we have on stellar evolution today
this star is in its autumn years now as
opposed to main sequence stars
wolf reyat's stars do not expand in
their final stages of life
their substantial mass holds all the
star's material together
in a dense and hot ball however after
losing a lot of its mass through
stellar wind the object will eventually
get destabilized
if current estimates are accurate wr102
appears to be ready to go supernova at
any point in the next 1500 years
bearing in mind that the distance
between the star and the earth is 10
000 light years it is highly likely that
the event has already taken place
a supernova would have been accompanied
by an extra powerful gamma-ray flare
fortunately our planet is too far away
to suffer
any pernicious effects of this dangerous
emission
wr 102 is comprised of rather heavy
chemical elements
and even iron its later evolution will
force it to contract to a critical point
the great explosion bringing the star's
life cycle to a close
will unleash processes of robust proton
and neutron capture
this way still heavier elements form
including transuranium ones
eventually wr 102 will be replaced by a
neutron star
a celestial body unbelievably hot and
dense
the former star's outer layers disrupted
by the explosion
will form a nebula slowly cooling off
it will give off heat to the space
around it
many billions of years later this
material will be able to form a new
planetary system
this is the way the large-scale
evolution of the universe
occurs supernova events release amounts
of new elements
enabling new planets asteroids and
comets to get born
these astronomical bodies form elaborate
systems bound by gravity
the elements making them up mutually
react to produce
infinite diversity of chemical compounds
that is why the cognition of the
universe is really and truly
quite endless
you